et
[Musique]
harcelé par gêne les shadoks crise quand
le tout pour le tout vont partir dans le
cosmos avec la lune pour chercher une
terres plus hospitalières
il allait s'enfoncer encore une fois
dans les profondeurs de l'espace et cela
sur une chaise lui crever déglingué
rafistolé qui pouvait les laisser en
plan n'importe quand
franchement c'était risque jadot qu
avait mis au point un système de
propulsion et de son invention
naturellement il fallait pompey mais ça
la population s'en chargerait en bas les
malheureux shadoks prisonniers voyaient
d'un assez mauvais oeil vous pensez bien
leurs derniers espoirs de délivrance son
volet nesat est modulé 1 c'est pas de
notre faute il versait rennais dernières
larmes sur cette terre ne connaîtrai
jamais et la population fut invité à
pomper c'est alors que commence à la
difficulté la population de poupées pas
la population ne voulait pas couper la
populace de refuser de pomper la
population était sur le dos les pattes
en l'air et s'en fichait telle mentalité
c'était donc ça la nouvelle génération
de shadocks lunaire des shadoks qui dont
ces jours où s'écrivaient des pages
parmi les plus grandioses de leur
histoire s'asseyait dessus mais ce
n'était pas de leur faute
les shadoks 9 était tombé malade il
avait attrapé le mal de lune le mal de
lune est une maladie universelle qui
s'attaque à tous mais dont on ne sait
rien sauf que cela se dirige très
simplement en tapant sur la partie
malade
c'est donc une maladie excessivement
intéressante sur le temps médical qu'il
est promis à un grand ami mais là
c'était beaucoup plus bas le mâle de
l'une s'était installé à l'intérieur des
chats d'autres et pour taper à
l'intérieur il aurait fallu un truc
spécial et ça on ne l'avait pas
la situation était tragique j'ai jeunes
sont réglés bombardait la lune trouée de
toupargel a sombré et les shadoks malade
refuse obstinément de pépé
tout semblait perdu mais j'attends nous
peut être pas le de 20 pompiers avaient
unités il restait encore la légende
[Musique]